primary elections are how political
parties in the United States pick their
strongest candidate to run for president
the parties do this by holding mini
elections in each of the states and the
candidates with the most votes from
these elections becomes the party's
official nominees these nominees then
face each other in the national election
for president but this isn't the whole
story there are five things that make it
a bit more complicated than that
complication number one primaries versus
caucuses in every state the local party
leaders decide how to run their
elections the two most common choices
are primaries and caucuses primaries are
just like standard elections go to the
polls whenever you can stand in the long
line hide in a booth then tick a box or
press a button and your vote is cast and
complete anonymity a caucus however is a
public vote people gather in groups
wherever space is available then
literally take sides in a room with
everyone else who likes the same
candidate the group's debate each other
and if people change their minds they
need to physically switch sides at the
end of the debates the party
representatives count the number of
people in each group if you leave too
early your vote doesn't count this
description of primaries and caucuses is
really all you need to know but the
specifics can vary wildly that's because
there are 50 states all of which hold at
least two primaries and caucuses for the
big parties and possibly more for the
small parties covering all the local
variants would take a tediously long
time which are short attention span for
boring political videos wouldn't
tolerate and you need to stay focused
because there are four more things to
come complication number two who can
vote in the national presidential
election all American citizens over the
age of 18 can vote with two exceptions
you can't live here or here but
primaries are in state elections with
lots of different rules most states and
parties will only let you vote in the
primary if you're an official member of
the party this is called a closed
primary because the voting is closed to
non party members but some citizens are
independence and not registered with any
party if you're an independent and live
in a state with closed party elections
tough luck no voting for you some states
however have semi-closed primaries where
independents can pick one and only one
primary to vote in parties allow this
because the presidential election is
often determined by independence so
knowing which candidates they like is
useful finally a few states and parties
really play it fast and loose with open
primaries here any citizen no matter
which party they're registered with can
pick a primary to vote in but it's not
just the states that have primaries
they're also held in the District of
Columbia and the off forgotten
territories holding primaries here is a
odd though considering that territorial
residents can't vote in the actual
presidential election lastly are the
Americans living abroad who depending on
the party vote in a block as though they
all live together in one big extra state
when all these elections take place
depends on complication number three who
votes when primaries aren't conducted
all at once but are spread out over a
year this leads to fights between the
states about who gets to be at the head
of the line and who is stuck at the back
inevitably last-minute leap frogging of
dates happens even though the parties
often take away votes from these uncivil
States when it comes to being number one
nobody beats New Hampshire who wrote it
into state law that their primary will
always be at least a week ahead of
everyone else's which isn't a problem
until some other state gets the bright
idea to do the same and then we have an
infinite loop in our system and have to
force quit the law but wait you say
doesn't Iowa already go first
yes but New Hampshire lets them get away
with it for two reasons first Iowa's
election is a caucus and so New
Hampshire is still technically the first
primary and seconded I wa is stupid and
doesn't matter
other states try to boost their
influence not by cutting in line but by
forming an alliance and holding their
primaries at the same time the biggest
alliance of the election cycle is called
Super Tuesday where depending on how
many states can agree with each other
around half of them might participate
giving out a whole pile of votes which
brings us to complication number four
votes that aren't votes so this whole
time you were probably thinking that
citizens gave votes straight to the
candidates but now instead the votes are
given to a bunch of guys called
delegates who in turn give them to the
candidates as requested maybe depending
on the state delegates might be required
to vote as the citizens did or they
might be completely free to ignore the
citizens and vote for whomever they want
who are these people the delegates are
local party VIPs such as state reps and
officials the more citizens who live in
a state the more delegates that state
gets later in the year when all the
states have finished their primaries the
delegates travel to a huge gathering for
their party called the national
convention it's here that the official
vote to select the party's nominee for
president happens but it's not just the
delegates who do the voting complication
number five super-delegates
super-delegates are the top members of
the party such as congressman and former
presidents they go to the National
Convention not to represent the people
but to represent the current party
establishment and can vote for whomever
they want depending on the party
super-delegates might be up to 20% of
the voters at the
National Convention usually by the time
the national convention happens all the
candidates save one have dropped out of
the race so the convention is just a
rubber stamp and a big party but if the
fight between candidates is still
ongoing the delegates and
super-delegates are the ones with the
final decision
in summary over the course of a year the
states plus DC plus the territories and
the Americans abroad hold their
primaries or caucuses when finished the
delegates representing the citizens who
voted in those elections travel to the
national convention most the delegates
are forced to vote as the citizens of
their state wanted them to but some of
them are free to vote as they like at
the National Convention the delegates
meet up with the super-delegates who
represent the best interests of the
party and together they make the final
decision on who will be the nominee for
president tired don't be because only
now does the race for the presidency
begin
of course you could skip all that and
jump straight into the election as an
independent the only downside to this
strategy is near certain defeat